[Music]
what's going on guys what's going on
it's been a minute man you know D said
it's only been a couple weeks and I I
should I should still be kicking I
should I shouldn't Miss A Beat what's
going on you shouldn't man you shouldn't
Miss A Beat
man how is how was your your uh holiday
how was it you still made content but H
how is uh see I still made content on my
um on my personal Channel but I said
everything I was supposed to do we were
supposed to do that last episode but you
know you had stuff going on I had stuff
going on I was like we just shut down
for for the the win got a hibernate man
got a
hibernate uh no man my my little uh
holiday was was pretty dope yeah I've
been doing content um I know we did uh
miss out on wbg for a couple weeks you
know obviously because it fell on
Christmas and New Year's Day so we said
okay the first time I actually mix
missed that show since we started it in
like February 2020 the first time we
ever was not on on the Monday night but
you know I was still doing my oneman
podcast and you know my regular vide so
yeah you know I'm back I'm ready I'm
back in the groove and I see you're
trying to get back in podcasting
Groove man yeah I a really I I I
appeared on certain people's podcast but
these days man so this is how my week is
okay Monday I don't really got a whole
lot going on Monday but I I want I want
to fix that so like want to like stream
or something uh
Tuesday that that's the day I normally
do like clips and stuff for IOP then I
got the attic show on Wednesdays
Thursdays uh I got a lot of stuff that
go like usually family stuff that goes
on that day Fridays I have King show and
usually Fridays I I will have the planet
Xbox just depends on what kitmo is doing
Saturdays is generally when I do the pre
stuff for
IOP uh you know CG's doing a lot of that
on Saturdays too and then Sunday's
obviously the podcast and then uh and
then I then it all goes again just in a
giant Circle giant giant circle of
hell hey man so so you sound like you're
busy every every day of the week huh I
I'm trying that that that's that's the
goal that's the goal okay you because
right now I I don't know if you guys
know but I did start the the addict
Arena that's my new YouTube channel
which is funny which is funny because
you know people say they want content
related to video
games but what I've
noticed is that people want spicy
content related to video games it is
what it is yeah so it's just like you
know
uh it's I would say that the addict
Arena so far has been a pretty good
success uh me and King has been over
there playing bers Gate 3 um so I'm
enjoying that man I'm enjoying that
anyone that wants to sub to the addict
Arena that is the the the channel right
there so definitely go over there you
know trying to only if you like streams
though you know I'm gonna still do some
streams over there talking about certain
topics but a lot of the streaming going
on over there it will be related
to um it'll be related to like games
like u i right now me and King are
streaming Boulders gate I I plan on
doing some pre-recorded stuff for other
with other people in the community uh
you know that that's generally where
that content's going to go I will use
that to my advantage sometimes when it
comes to certain type of content that I
can't normally do on the the gaming
addict Channel and because you know I
tried to to get all streaming off the
gaming addict Channel you know is that
gonna hurt that channel in the logistic
long run of things I don't know but my
mindset is is even if there's a chance
it could hurt that channel there's not
really a whole lot of reasons to to
continue going down that route if that
makes sense like especially I could just
you know the majority of the ways that
that channel is going to grow is through
Let's Plays and stuff like that and to
me when it comes to that it's going to
be a different consumer base than what
we generally get you know that's going
to be more in the let's play Community
that's why I'm reaching out to people
like Chase uh chase money trying to get
a lot more people in that Community
because I want their viewership because
their viewership will watch that type of
content and that's not saying that no
one that watches our content will watch
it but I know that the crossover is
going to be a lot smaller than you know
necessarily going from IP to the atct
show they're different shows but they're
generally around the same type of
content uh doing doing let's plays is
completely different that's that's a
totally different crowd you're 100%
right that's a totally different crowd
because that you know like I crowd they
want to they tune in to hear opinions a
little trash talking you know not
gameplay but yeah you right I mean
there's some some people that will
probably sub just out of love for you it
depends what I what I stream too like
let's say I stream hellblade 2 when it
comes out yeah yeah numbers of that not
if you stream like pent you probably
won't get a good
number but I hopefully with any luck you
know we've been getting a lot of uh
review codes from Xbox here lately uh so
you know if I get the hellblade review
coverage my plan is to make a a
pre-recorded series of hellblade and
launch like three of them at launch yeah
when the game comes out that'll be
that'll be perfect
there and especially someone like me
that that didn't really want a big fan
I'll probably stream hellblade one
before hellblade 2 comes out uh so you
know it is but what you been playing I
played a lot of games over the holiday
man I ain't going to lie to you like
that yeah man I've been um you know I've
been trying to tackle because I've been
off for a couple weeks I'm been trying
to tackle this uh backlog don't don't
use the fact you've been off for a
couple weeks I just Tred to do that and
you you shut me down what I said don't
use the fact you've been off I've been
off for a couple weeks n we ain't allow
to do that oh well like you like for my
regular job you
know definitely been off of there but
yeah I've been playing a lot of games
man I've been playing um I you know I'll
go back to some old games play some old
games I go back to the new games um what
I've been playing um what have I been
playing damn I don't even remember what
I've been playing I still haven't
finished Starfield yet I still plan on
taking my time with that game but Dam
what have I been
playing I don't remember bro I've been
playing so many old old games these last
weeks um let be been playing the
PlayStation fans because it's so easy to
play yeah that's that's really what I've
been doing looking at these clowns on on
social
media it's funny man uh so you know I
over the week uh the holiday I I played
a lot of um games that I missed you know
I've been playing a lot of Resident Evil
4 remake I've also been playing some
some Texas Chainsaw Massacre I've been
playing a lot of
finals yeah I've actually really been
enjoying in finals okay all it's it's
good man it's a nice little thing
someone wants to know have you played
Liza p no I haven't man those those
style of games that's that's not my
Boogie yeah I've been playing tomb raid
black John you must have seen me playing
I've been playing like a lot of older
games even though I still need to go
back to cyber punk I need to go back to
Star Star Wars Jedi Survivor I've been
playing Tomb Raider for some reason bro
I have no idea why loving it like I've
never played it before I'll be playing
Kane and
Lynch um two actually man brought the
connect to the family room playing some
connect over the weekend with my kids
you know my kids they grew up on it but
of course they older now but they still
remember it and having a good time man
so yeah I've been playing a lot of older
stuff bro yeah I uh I'm actually going
to stream Li
a I'm going to stream that I
believe the eth I think I said said the
eth I'll be streaming Li of p and people
like saying that like that's like one of
the hardest Souls light games and I'm
like I'll be the judge of
that it's like because for some reason
there's been certain games that I I
respect people's opinions when it comes
to how they handle these certain types
of um
content and what I've noticed
is I've noticed that the these
individuals um when it comes to certain
games that I just didn't have issues
with
they're having issues with that game so
it's kind of it's kind of interesting
and some of the other games that I would
have issues with they they weren't
having issues with it so I'm kind of
curious how that goes because I
guess you know I play these games pretty
religiously at this
point uh so I'm curious how all this is
going to end up turning out yeah
interesting stuff man yeah so uh
how what what have you been keeping up
with like the news thing since all this
happened because I I I've definitely
been keeping up with everything going
out um
well i' be keeping up with everything to
be honest with you man I'm always on
Twitter looking for Content uh I've been
keeping up with everything I've been
keeping up with you know because usually
this time of year is pretty slow you
know because everybody's on Christmas
break but I've definitely been keeping
up with some of
the HP y that's been going on in the
community how that's not
hard listen um you know I don't want to
start the new year off being messy on
your channel iron Lord's Channel but I'm
just looking at
how all of a sudden third party
games count they matter After People
specifically
saying Xbox has no games because they
had no first party content now third
party exclusives are okay
so and I actually have a couple receipts
probably want to expose a couple people
when I do a video maybe my dark man
podcast tomorrow but is there some stuff
I've been looking at in the community
you've been disgusted I've been
disgusted but I've also been just just
looking paying attention not saying much
but just looking at certain You' been
screenshotting too much oh I'll be
screenshotting a lot a lot some of the
fellow Xbox homies have been screenshot
stuff also and yeah I've been just
waiting for the right time to drop some
of these receipts because these guys are
out here Wilding if you if you ask me I
mean you can't say Xbox has no games and
all they have is Halo gears and fora and
they don't have no new first party you
know they have no first party uh games
and then all of a sudden third party
games is great because Sony doesn't have
many first party games and you know well
like you know how how you feel about
Jack M Johnny
I like I like Jack even is hilarious
even when he roastes XBox he's funny as
hell Jack M been been putting the the
PlayStation brand all on the offensive
for a while now he he's definitely one
of those people that he's like n we
ain't doing that like what what he's
he's definitely like one of the
PlayStation people that I feel is
genuinely understanding what kind of bad
situation PlayStation's currently in
right now and is paying
attention and he noticed there there's
cause for concern because at even like
us if we go back to last generation
there were some cause there was a cause
for concern at one point with Xbox like
Dam Xbox you know that's why we I will
fully admit I was one of the guys that
kept on saying wait to E3 I kept on
saying wait to E3 because there was
concern like why are they not showing
any new games why are there no new IPS
and we talked about that
but what's funny is people say Oh
They'll just say wait till ether what
else am I supposed to say right I mean
that's the thing though so there was con
a cause for concern back then and Us
Xbox guys talked about it it wasn't
until 2018 where they addressed you know
with just announcing those Studios they
address some some needs okay they're
headed in the right direction but for
somebody guys I was in listen I don't
talk to ponies a lot I just grab
screenshots and I use them for my
content but I got into a discussion with
this PlayStation guy and he kept on
talking about console sales I would say
yo man but PlayStation has some concerns
Spider-Man 2 costing $315 million that
should be a concern blah blah blah blah
blah blah we would that be nextbox 3 to
one I said okay but you're not concerned
about no firings layoffs game
cancellations Studios being closed
they're still beating Xbox 3 to one I
said Okay okay so they have no concern
and jackm was like really the only one
that's out there saying there should we
should pay attention closely to what's
being what's happening I think when it
comes to like PlayStation Fanboys losing
their [__] I think the last time we seen
it really bad is when they first started
porting stuff to
PC like CU they according to them a lot
of them stop playing games then you know
they they they they dropped the
PlayStation brand remember how many we
say that oh you keep doing this we're
going to drop the PlayStation brand and
then when you see the numbers on these
games that's being sold they're good but
not that good considering you know these
these games to me they would be better
if they had like day and date because I
feel like by the time these or at least
six months by the time these games come
out I feel like all of the steam is gone
and that's why you're not seeing these
games sell the greatest on PC and I'm
not saying that like they're flops on PC
considering how many years ago they came
out they're they're doing decent on PC
but I I will say that you devalued your
console not the brand the console to put
these games on PC and I don't see like
the
return is there you know what I'm saying
I feel like if we knew what C th sold I
bet you C out sold all of those games on
PC yeah so good but but I mean like
you're right but we also got to realize
this 2024 and with the acception of
Nintendo the
consoles they're definitely a huge part
of the ecosystem of course they are
because they're still millions of
consoles being sold every year but they
don't mean as much as they meant maybe
in the 90s or the early 2000s because PC
is growing it's growing consoles still
haven't pass no console has passed the
PS2 so and that was 20 plus years ago so
and I don't expect any conso to out sell
the PS2 anytime soon so I think PC is a
is a big thing and PC Gamers grow every
day I think that
people are starting to realize that what
sells to mainstream doesn't necessarily
sell games you know PE if it's not a
fortnite or connect to a massive hobby
like like Madden
2K you know Minecraft Like These are
very unique situations that sell a lot
of copies it doesn't mean that the
people playing these games will buy Last
of Us or or you know anything and I
think the reason and you know people can
argue with me all they want and I know
this is like a really hot take when it
comes to the Nintendo Community I think
that's one of the reasons that Nintendo
doesn't care about third party support
because right you can argue that the
lack of third party supports makes all
their games sell better because there's
no
competition yeah yep you know what and
Nintendo at just like you said nobody
buys a Nintendo platform for a third
party nobody buys Nintendo for Call of
Duty hell they don't even have Call of
Duty right now nobody buys Nintendo for
third party like they buy Nintendo for
Nintendo games and Xbox and
PlayStation they don't really have that
yes do some people buy a PlayStation for
Spider-Man yeah I'm sure some do but the
majority don't the majority buy their
PlayStation or even their Xbox for Call
of Duty fortnite Apex Legends those
games man um and it is what it is so if
you think about with the whole
PlayStation and there single player
games which are pretty good games I
don't think having one game cost 315
million
that's a single player only no
microtransactions no no ways of getting
extra money after the game releases I
don't think that's sustainable and
that's why we're here now you know
people still want to talk about console
sales okay I think people need to
understand that you know I personally
feel like there's there's other issues
in the industry I think you know maybe
we need developers and like publisher
leads to like really go over these but
when I see something like Spider-Man
what almost 300 million to make no it
wasn't almost it was 315 million to make
315 million I don't I don't see how
that's possible you know what I'm saying
like like to me is
it are they just I don't understand how
well and PE and then like Jason shrier
went out and said that everyone that
develops makes 130,000 a year and I know
that's not true because I know plenty of
developer friends that don't make that
kind of money that's a damn good living
right there 130 yeah yeah so it's just
like is that including the
marketing I don't know brother you know
these are valid questions because I
would think the majority of the budget
goes to the employees because the these
games take years to develop so if a 20
hour game takes five years they have to
pay those people for five years but like
you said of
um I can't see everybody getting paid
130,000 I can't see that either yeah so
so 130,000 and we said 200 people yeah
is that how many people is that SN I
think it's 400 people but like they got
they working on different projects yeah
so that's 65 million times that by how
long did it take them to make that
four I'll say four yeah four yeah so so
not to mention I inflated the hell out
of it 260 million and that's inflating
the hell out of it and that's with how
many employees 500 500 yeah that 3155
seems crazy bro
like I can understand when you add like
bills uh what when you put like the I
assume they own the building that they
work out of I don't know uh but just
like I don't know part of me just like
sees that and this is just me talking
from an influencer don't really know
anything about development
cost I feel like some of these games
just have ated
budgets and some mismanagement has been
done a lot I do I especially at the
beginning I feel like there's a lot of
mismanagement and and rightfully so
you're not going to have any of these
Studios automatically know how they're
going to do things it's going to be a
lot of like rinse and repeat trying this
doesn't work drop it trying this doesn't
work drop it and I think that's the
reason so many companies are so
comfortable with sequels uh with because
new IPS you start with a clean
whiteboard and people don't want to Star
clean whiteboards y it's just like I'm
not saying that these prices aren't
valid I just feel like if you want if
you want us to be more sympathetic to
how much games cost because that's what
you hear all the time you you hear oh
okay you know well okay someone said um
you also have you also here's the thing
they they take loyalties from
that like they take loyalties from that
I I don't I don't know if they give them
like a lot of money up front uh they
probably do but is that going to be part
of the budget because they're acting
like this is the budget to make the game
yeah they kind of said this the budget
now we now we do know there's there's
there's like licensing cost and
royalties and stuff like that
but I don't know man know like not that
you said that that you looked those
numbers up and you calculate that's just
a crazy number man that's it's like
almost a hundred million difference yeah
it's a crazy number it's not it's like
75 million or something like that it's
just that's a lot of money that's a
that's another that's a Ratchet and
Clank so I mean maybe they have to fly
like a to New York like a bunch of times
and and you know but then again like I
feel like they did a lot of that work
they did all that already right they did
that already I mean it's just I don't
know man I think it's weird because
Shawn Laden today or was it yesterday he
mentioned those budget again because uh
foxy UK mentioned the the price of these
games being so expensive and sea Leen
said yo I I believe we're gonna hear a
lot about that in
2024 and I know you you know I'm sorry
go ahead I feel like they should be more
transparent tell us the budgeting tell
us not maybe where you're spending the
money but what what what you're spending
money on in terms of like cost in terms
of where they're living like because I
feel like if you want the industry to be
more accepted on raising prices explain
why prices are being raised that's you
know that's not a bad point but you know
Gamers you know guys don't give a damn
yeah they gonna be like yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever y'all are rich y'all got
it don't raise the game to $100 you know
the thing is is we we've seen in other
scenarios especially like Indie
developers where when people are just
transparent people are a little bit more
willing to take whatever they're dealt
with like well it I personally feel like
there there's no way in hell where if
they they're transparent with us where
everyone is not going to like that I
feel like there's they will get the
sympathetic of a lot more people than
they did just say yo we raising prices
why because we said so like that's where
I think I I I
think we and it's not necessarily say we
don't need to know it's not about
knowing you know where the money's being
go it's just part of me just feels like
when you tell me they spent 300 and what
25 uh 315 million
yeah I just have a hard time
understanding where that money's going
and and you know what I agree with you
because if it was a multiplayer games as
a service you would kind of get that
because you know the Halo infinite
probably had a big budget Call of Duty
games have big budgets like that but a
single player only game costing that
much just doesn't I don't know man and
and and you know people got to realize
that you know because I mentioned this
on social media on Twitter and some
PlayStation guys came after me like how
how do you why do you care bro you
should care I care about the health of
the industry I care 100% I care about
the health of the industry of a guy like
Shawn leaden who was running PlayStation
saying this is not
sustainable if XBox was out there
bleeding
money I will be concerned because I love
video games and I I'm concerned about
the health of the industry we've seen uh
so many different types of games uh uh
like like even Assassin's Creed Mirage
right the last game was a smaller game
because they did not want to make that
huge open world game again and I don't
know how well marage did but you can
play the game and tell is the you can
tell instantly that the budget was
lowered from Valhalla still a pretty
decent game but you can tell instantly
uh so cyber Punk was 13 33 million did
they announce that somewhere yeah and
and another thing like is that is that
all the money they put into fixing the
[__] game that they tried to sell us
years ago too like or is that just what
they spent going into the game because
all that matters like I'm not saying
look I'm just saying when we talking
about this type of money I just
feel like as as a mindset and I think I
think the pandemic had something to do
with it too I think some of the I don't
I talked to some developer friends and
they said the reason games are taking
longer to make right now isn't
necessarily because games are taking
longer to make because we're seeing the
games from covid coming out and they
took longer to make yeah they did but
that doesn't necessarily mean every game
from now on is going to take what it
took to to make a game during Co that's
why when you saw like Boulders gate devs
come out to say this is our Co
game like it took six years because they
were developing it during
Co probably would have took four if they
weren't deal dealing with Co right
because you gota I I know I know certain
Studios didn't do [__] for six months
during Co that's crazy bro six months
half a year they do [__] that's a long
time right that's crazy yeah and because
they
couldn't hey hellblade probably would
have been out last year if it wasn't for
K winner hellblade would have been out
last year for was in for Co yeah like it
delayed stuff 6 months to a year and a
half minimum yeah that's why you're
seeing PlayStation have such a huge gap
between announcements because the game
that came out and got pushed over the uh
the the Finish Line those games were far
their in development and they were able
to push them M the finish line but
you're seeing the games that were at the
beginning of development during the
covid right now they're not announcing
them because they have nothing to show
because they all were delayed six months
to to a year and a half
now I think you'll see PlayStation
announcements this year but that's the
reason you didn't see nothing last year
is because they had nothing to show you
right
right and it's also why you know Xbox
had a year like 2022 where they didn't
have a lot of first-party content
because that that Gap you know their
games were much earlier like you said
the games they were developing was much
earlier than some of PlayStation games
which were mostly PS4 games with a
couple of exceptions like rash and Clank
and returnal but all the other ones more
PS4 games that were a few years into
development and even they still got
delayed a little bit but they were able
to get those games out and you're right
about that I mean it's just that's just
how it goes and returnal came out a
buggy mess so I I I don't know if
Horizon did I remember Horizon had a lot
of issues when it came out uh Last of Us
Part Two that was at the beginning of
the pandemic wasn't it it was right it
was right at the beginning yeah it was
like June of 2020 yeah
that game was pretty polished though and
I think that's because the majority of
that game was done before the pandemic
yeah it was
um so Spider-Man had a lot of
issues so I mean you really want to get
technical PlayStation really hasn't
developed a Nong bug free game in a few
years at this
point um I will say Ratchet and Clank
ran butterly smooth but that was before
the pandemic too
so R Clank came of
2021 what ratchet and Clay MH then it
might have been right there I think it
was right there before the pandemic it's
just like look like there's a lot of
issues these these companies are running
into and I will say money is definitely
one of them uh but you know look at
stuff you see how often do we go of year
and then we see a company or Jason Shri
like leak something that says
mismanagement millions of money millions
of dollars wasted I think some that's
going on along here too and I'm not
saying that there's not room to improve
or not room to improve I don't know
anything you know the difference between
me and a lot of other people is I ain't
gonna come out here and tell you my
words or facts are
Stone I'm an ignorant mother I'm not
cussing okay I'm ignorant to the matter
I don't know I'm just telling you when I
see something cost $315 million to make
I'm just like what did you spin that
on and that is a assuming everyone that
worked at Insomniac makes
$130,000 a year and I don't think that's
realistic I don't because we could
probably go on indeed or whatever it
is and I bet you if we looked up the
salaries to these companies it's not
going to be 130,000 a year per person
yeah because that's a lot like
you I wish I had time I should have like
a little bit of pre-research I could
have at the very least like hit up some
of the people I know that that how
much does a game
developer make in a
year I'm thinking the average is around
60 or something 60
70 all right so New York's about 120 oh
okay but when I look down here I I'm
seeing 6
like there's only like four or five
states that have that kind of
high high level and this is
just C is probably one theia is in cali
California 116,000 yes so so maybe
that's right Foria because they're based
out of California right and but we got
to remember too how many contracts
contractors was used as well because
they were paid hour they're not paid uh
yearly or anything like that right
contractors yeah cuz I think every
Studio use contractors at one one point
or another so yeah that's something else
yeah yes because that's the reason they
they rely on contractors because they
don't have to pay benefits they just
have to say yo do this and we'll come
back bra I don't I'm gonna be real with
you br I don't care what you gotta say
in the comments section not even a
little bit I mean well his comment
actually is is okay because of saying
what Shan leaden saying how the the the
rising cost of development and the games
prices really doesn't you
know it like the consumer the consumers
isn't keeping Pace with Rising
development cost meaning the prices of
the games are not going up but the
development but the budgets are going
way up so I mean then then there's that
conversation we were talking about $70
games you know me personally I never had
a problem with $70
games
honestly um but if you
start when you end huh uh when does it
end though $70 $80 $90 10000 I've seen
people saying they'd be act like they'd
be grateful to pay $100 for a game I'm
not grateful to pay $100 right
yeah but you have to be real if we look
at it a guy my age that's been gaming
forever I remember in the with the N64
Super Nintendo days those games cost
7080 bro here
cartridge we charge $100 for for a game
you know what's gonna happen they're
gonna waste more money making that game
yeah I don't think it's gonna fix the
issue they're gonna have more money to
blow yeah and people say well if you pay
$100 it's gonna no it's not cuz all
that's going to do is give people at the
highend more money for shareholders more
money bonuses for the higher like we
like to only watch half of Jason shri's
Rants and not the other half Jason Shri
came out multiple times and said some of
the shadiest stuff in the industry is
done on the higher end and stuff and you
you make it seem like we're actually
gonna like us paying $100 is gonna
generate
something yeah I agree with you on that
um because if we pay $100 like you said
they're the the budgets are going to
keep on ballooning so here here here's
brat as long as the market demand exists
for Triple A we'll continue seeing these
games is it though is it demanding for
Triple A because I can make an argument
that the market doesn't demand Triple A
fortnite Minecraft these games might be
high quality but would you consider them
the Triple A that M that Sony
makes I don't know I think that's a a
good conversation be had Roblox wow yeah
that's a good point the industry is not
playing these games that's the reason
we're having these conversations if
everyone was making Minecraft money
fortnite money GTA 5 is a triple A game
but you guys get if roblock money would
this be an issue there'd be plenty of
money to go around ad you're making
great points the biggest games the only
ones that's Triple A are are the sports
theh sports titles those are triaa games
because the budgets are pretty high Call
of Duty right if you think about the top
games that's every
year those are the really the only games
that's like Triple A Call of Duty of
course GTA is a big time triple that's a
quad jupa game but they're gonna make
their money so you're exactly you're
actually right about that and people say
you generate more money layoffs will
stop okay then why the hell did epic lay
people off last year they probably make
one of the
most most money in the whole industry
and they still laid people off they did
yeah so it's just like no like is an
issue from from the top this is not an
issue on the developers it's not an
issue on how many people support stuff
most of the time they'll sit there and
they'll put come out and buy U Horizon
forbidden West you buy it it's buggy as
hell come out and buy R returnal you buy
it it's buggy as hell come out and buy
red fall what the hell come out and buy
and then what's funny is you got games
like Starfield that functionally run
decent and then
people attack it like it's not running
decent look there are some PC builds
most likely it was the Nvidia stuff and
and that's that's bethesda's fault for
making an agreement with AMD instead of
building that game for every graphic
card I think that's the reason that
Starfield is in the situation it is
right now because it like look like you
want my opinion don't buy any triaa
games because they're the ones that have
no problem cutting games up making you
pay for it they have no problem making
you
um
like though add it yeah no problem
shipping buggy games they don't care
yeah but the but the tripa games is the
games that we like like us the hardcore
Gamers like I don't play fortnite I know
King Day loves it I don't play it but
kolos everybody that does play it but
like a game that I
loved the Kalisto protocol I love that
game I thought it was phenomenal it
flopped there's never going to be
another one like the studio might not be
able to make another game so the gaming
industry I just think we got to
understand
that excuse me it's not going
to it's it's going to change brother
it's going to change it's not going to
be the same old Gaming industry that
we're used to um I believe Xbox game
pass helps Xbox Microsoft obviously been
Microsoft helps Xbox but even all of
their games are not going to be triaa
games whatever double find next game is
probably not going to be Triple A
they're not a huge triaa Studio they
said look up you know uh top 10 where it
said UFC 2K Mortal Kombat Super Mario
RPG EA Super Mario wonders okay that's
cool these people bought these games let
talk about where the actual players are
because they're not playing these games
they're playing war zone they're playing
Minecraft they're playing fortnite
they're spending mad money in these
games as as well you really want to get
technical you could probably find a
domino that started all this and it's
called free to play that's probably what
the problem with the industry is people
are no longer spending money on games
they're they they rather spend all their
money in freeto playay games how many
people you thinks like keing it's like
you know what I don't need to keep
buying these broken games I'm G save
that money put it all in
fortnite because at least I know
fortnite gonna
work see see but also the the longevity
like you just said like all those games
you know talking about like Mortal
Kombat and all those games are great um
but you don't you're not going to see
too many people like like you're not
going to see mortal komat in the top 10
or top five play games a whole year
straight you know what I'm saying like
you'll see Cod or fortnite or you know
Apex or those games so all I'm saying is
that the gaming
industry is changing slightly guys and
we need to realize it I always say from
Xbox point of view also from a
PlayStation point of view we just got to
pay attention because some guys want to
still talk like it's 2006 with console
sales and this happened and that
happened I and I tell
people if everything was all good with
PlayStation why did they try to change
their strategy at it why did they try to
change their strategy of they've been
changing their strategy for years yeah
it's nothing new but people want to pay
attention to it people don't want to pay
ATT what funny is on we we called what
the hell is going on with PlayStation
years
ago got massive amounts of people
leaving naughty dog and all these top
tier Studios and then they wonder why
when they're not releasing nothing
because they they don't have
to game appeared to a different market
segments to dart's point the industry is
changing uh where you have a dynamic
Market no the majority of these people
are playing games as a service it's not
it's not a different Market most these
people pick up all these games but what
do they go back to
Dart they go back to to the games at the
service they go back to the Call of
Duties to the for nights I played
Destiny for six years seven years yeah
and when I played Destiny I bought a
fraction of the games that I bought last
year when I didn't play
Destiny and I'm bet you those metrics
are similar in every game's the service
because it's like it's like a it's like
throwing someone in a giant pit and
shutting the top yeah they're gonna
they're gonna do what's in the pit they
can't do anything else it took me years
to get out of
it and that's what these developers want
they want guys like you that was
spending money investing in their game
for six or seven years they want that
they want that fortnite audience they
want that Apex that Call of Duty
audience that's what play PlayStation
wants that's what Xbox wants Nintendo
they don't care because their first
party sells 40 50 million games a piece
but that's what they want man like you
said Roblox bro what what is the budget
of Roblox I wonder what was the the
initial budget of
Roblox I'm guaranteed it wasn't $35
million and and that that's another
thing it's like look like no one
supports the games that they try stuff
like you clo protocol uh I liked it for
what I played of it I didn't like the
the melee thing over and over again it's
just like there's a reason that they're
going back to these older games they're
probably significantly cheaper to make
remakes remas yeah you're right
man let's get these super chats and move
on you got a $2h from Webb Dave Addis D
what do you want from the Xbox showcase
that's the next so we'll get into that
that's the homie web Dave man yeah $2
Super Chat from JD gamer pathetic Port
begging ponies got no game # no
PlayStation 6 oh I see hey hey talk that
you JD hey talk that stuff JD start off
2024 in the right way I love it all
right so um there's a rumored well I
don't even say it's a rumored thing a
lot of people
expect history to repeat itself we'll
actually get another uh direct another
Xbox direct whatever they call developer
direct if it is we'll say four games
what do you think's going to be there
and what you want to be at this event
because I think if if if history repeats
itself it's going to be similar to what
it was last time yeah yeah um well well
first obvious uh hellblade
to if this happens it's 100% going to be
there um with a release date because I
know people like why didn't they show
the release date at the game awards and
I think that's why it's going to show it
there yep um that's going to 100% be
there I'm expecting the game launch
probably April maybe um to Bourne is
going to be there um I really believe
that some people saying it's G to be
another Shadow drop they're saying may
maybe a double F game or something
they've been working on for a few years
might bestda remake that that would be
cool so yeah rumored that Fallout 3 and
Oblivion were being
remade
okayo both that' be pretty dope so yeah
I'm I'm expecting some type of Shadow
drop now the one um some some people I
saw Cobel had his prediction he said he
think AOW might slip to
2025 which is possible yeah which is
100% possible um
but would be there just because how many
times they've like reworked that game
yeah I think uh you know if they need
more time give them more time uh you
know if I trust anything when it comes
to obsidian in if if you give them the
time they need they will
deliver I think stalker to will be there
and I'm going say they're going to have
five games the fifth
one I think South midnight because
everybody's telling me South to
Midnight's probably gonna be there then
you do the
timeline we happy if you came out of
2018 they had a couple of dlc's but for
the most part they they probably have
been working on South the midnight since
2018 it's is about to be 2024 the six
years so if you include the
covid that six years probably covers
that game being pretty much done almost
done I think South and midnight they
they might Shadow drop south of midnight
oh that'll be dope because if you think
about it they haven't showed nothing on
that game for some reason they haven't
showed anything yeah I I believe that
game was definitely enough in
development to show stuff last year
that's a great Point yeah like I said
six years why would you not show the
game play unless the first time you see
the gameplay you want to end that
announcement with and it's live right
now after the
show that'd be interesting very
interesting yeah David coin ofal has
been in development uh for a while but
like adct said they re they reworked the
game a couple of times so I can see TR
you guys wanted the rework you guys
wanted the
rework so yeah but if you know I listen
South midnight we happy if you had so
much potential to me but you think about
that was a crowdfunded game um and they
working under Microsoft with the game
they want to make with Microsoft
resources so I'm extremely excited to
see what they gonna what South to it's
not South the dirt night you POS it's
South to midnight how dare
you you got to give them an a for
creativity they be Ro to me bro yeah
list pieces of trash um yeah man so I
I'm excited bro I am excited
man I
think I think you you're on to something
with the uh south of
midnight I think they're going
to show hellblade with in-depth
combat and then they'll announce a
release date I think uh I think it's
like August September oh you think it's
late
I don't I don't think it's G to be like
it might be the like
meish said it's closer than than you
think but what what in a corporate sense
what's really
close within the next six months or it
could be a year I would want that I
would want that I want it to come out
sooner rather than later so we can stop
talking about hellblade yeah because I'm
not probably going to enjoy it too much
I'll still play it because I feel like I
I need to at least try the game out but
but you know and I'll probably go back
to the the first one it's just I need to
actually get a hold of this game and try
it out um double fine definitely could
be a potential thing you know and that's
if they even Shadow drop something they
might not Shadow drop right right we're
just assuming because they did it last
year you know I do feel like with the
amount
of
positive the positive feedback they got
for shadow dropping uh high five Rush M
I think that might be something they
potentially do maybe they were going to
announce something La uh last year damn
it's weird saying last year last year
during the E3 show whatever you want to
call it but then they pulled it because
of the you know reception they got for
high-fi Rush you know what adct who was
that that told somebody said that South
to midnight was supposed to be at Xbox
Showcase in
2022 but they decided to hold it until
2023 who's
did you hear that oh sh add talking to
his
girl so what somebody told me south of
that exact the the same south of
midnight trailer they dropped last year
in
2023 showcase 2023 they were going to
show it in 2022 but Xbox decided not to
show it because they wanted to go with
the 12mon thing in 2022 somebody told me
that and to be honest that could that
sounds kind of true to be honest with
you um because yeah at the last minut
they say yo we're going to go with this
12 Monon thing we're going on these show
games that's dropping within the next 12
months which of course didn't happen but
if that's the case I do believe South
midnight could potentially drop this
year hey you remember that Jessie P yeah
somebody said that bro I don't remember
who said it but somebody said that and
like I said if you think about it that
definitely sounds like it was possible
so yeah I think uh I think it's
definitely possible when it comes to
stuff I I'm very curious you know be
crazy if they don't even do a show no
yeah that would be crazy but we're
hearing so much the homie Tim Dog said
they are so I'm GNA say it is happening
yeah I I'm just I'm curious on that they
like throw random stuff at us that we
didn't expect like we get like a fable
and and they announce that this year so
because I don't I don't think Fable is
coming out next year or this year but do
think that I think 2025 yeah I do think
that um I don't want to see it at E3 uh
but it's GNA be interesting man it's
gonna be interesting all right so let's
let's move on
to gears and banjo I'm sure you've seen
people talk about gears and banjo yeah
let's get these super chats real quick
fight out super chat from JD gamer those
that try and stand in the way of chances
are bound to be rolled up and crushed by
change Microsoft supporting Xbox as a
pillar in the company is a
change that's that's definitely a change
bro because in the past they really
didn't support them like that true yeah
we got $5 Super Chat from JD gamer
pathetic Port begging ponies got no
games running around changing their
narrative as uh on the week we the
weekly uh what's next Xbox can't win
because X comes after P hey JD they will
probably make up something like that
bro yeah these Naros are man these Naros
are crazy out here bro they changing
them like crazy we got a $2 JD game
pathetic poor backing ponies got no
games hash no ps6 JD gamer is talking
that trash we got a we got a $2 super
from Spartan 661 PS fans are gorling
while the foot while the boot is on
their neck
yeah it's going to be interesting hey
they hey the Xbox home he talking trash
bro um man I love
it all right so let's uh let's let's
move on to gears and banjo so rumored
that gears is going to be uh something
gears is going to be announced this year
one of the developers was kind of like
hinting at it yeah I'm also 2024 yeah
I'm also very curious on you know the
fact that it's rumored that banjo is
getting um it was green lit at the
beginning in that last year uh so that
that's going to be ious that might be an
E3 announcement because here's my thing
I don't see them re like doing a new
banjo I see them remaking banjo one so
to me I think that' be a good decision
how long would that realistically
take three years maybe four because such
an old game it probably take four years
still I think we'll see announc before
in 2025 and it'll come out in 2026 yeah
I can see that um let me or they want
shut people like me up and they give us
the announcement this
year it's possible I'm okay let me tell
you my opinion um
gears I think everybody's waiting for
Gears we are uh we're anxious for Gears
because you know last generation they
did gears four and five three years in
between so people kind of like okay you
know that's cool let us miss gears a
little bit in Xbox said okay they let us
miss gears and the last gears came out
and uh you want talk about the expansion
that was 2020 but 2019 the the last time
of a four fles gears game came
out I'm ready for new gears I'm ready to
see where they taking the franchise
because I enjoy F some people say they
Ain like five for some reason I thought
five was pretty good but I do want to
see Marcus Phoenix being the protagonist
again the main
protagonist um I'm I can't wait I
believe gears is going to be a showpiece
I believe the Coalition is going to
really show out with the game as far as
the game's visuals I think it's going to
be that game to make people say damn
kind of how like hellblade at the game
awards people was like
damn I could I was like whoa this is
what we was waiting for you know that
that game that feels and looks next gen
um but the looks of it I believe
coalation is Gonna Knock Out the park
now me
personally banjo I can give two damns
but it is Xbox first party now and Phil
says uh he hear so so what he say I hear
you banjo fan so it makes you think they
have something brought banjo
specifically yeah but I'm curious if
this is true which I'm thinking they are
developing who's making it that's what
I'm curious I think someone from AC
division would make sense because it's
awfully funny that this get yeah this
gets greenlit at the beginning of last
year it makes me feel like they were
under the assumption that they were
going to W that they were going to win
that and I think they can go from the
mindset look we're going to contract you
to make Banjo Kazooie um if if we win
the lawsuit and we take we take your
company home you'll just be working on a
first party game if we don't win the
lawsuit you'll be finishing banjo kuzui
for us right yo you know what if it's
like a studio like Toys for Bob I'mma
tell you Crash Bandicoot 4 I thought was
a highly under R game I bought it I said
let me buy it and I finished that game
and like it was really that good someone
said in my comment section of a video I
made and I think it would this would be
amazing I I don't they would ever do
this but if they made a bandri Kazooie
game a brand new one and you find out
conquer is the main
antagonist yeah I don't think they would
do that imagine that though like just
sit and imagine it would be dope banjo
going up against conquer
voice everything con be
drunk it just it' be like one of those
scenarios where we come across conquer
and he just steals the the the screen
you know what I'm say yeah I don't know
if they mix those two games together but
that would be funny though I actually
feel like they it would be amazing if
they made a universe with all these
little characters that they don't do
nothing with like conquer
banjo uh Crash Bandicoot Spyro I think
you could easily put those games
together in like its own little world
yeah like the broad from recoil do
something with her man man that
character has potential to me banjo
versus Marcus Phoenix come on now I just
think conquer as a main antagonist would
really sell
well yeah I think it would really sell
well and then people sit there and say
well these games they could to sell will
do something with them you know put them
in their own little Universe you I mean
hold on hold on Addie conquer is the
main an I don't know man people love
conquer they don't want to boo him they
don't want to be mad at him I think I
don't think that's going to encourage
people to boo him though okay it could
be one of those things where conquer you
think conquer is the main anagist but
someone's manipulating conquer okay now
that's different because I don't want to
okay I might do a spoiler for the last
of us two
spoiler you don't want a Avy moment I
don't want to I don't want Ellie to be a
boss like in that game where Ellie was a
boss I was like what the f bro why am I
fighting Ellie I know I'm my I'm Abby
right now but that pissed me
off like I said that game was a
technical Masterpiece but there was so
much stuff about that story that pissed
me off bro imagine like running in the
conquer and he's in like a like a giant
banjo suit like just just [__] with
him he comes out drunk and stuff like
you could do so much with conquer like
you could do so and I think you would do
very well as an antagonist because you
know he's a likable character he'd be
like one of those characters that you
want to not like but you can't help but
the light like he just shows up on the
screen vo somebody said Voodoo Vin n you
can keep him in that game you can keep
him in that
game the high-f five Rush developer
should make conquer I could see
that I wonder what they're making next I
wonder it's going to be a evil within
three
probably might do do a high five Rush
too yeah so no high on life developers
oh you say high on life oh okay I'm
sorry I might rush sorry oh that that
game that game to me was underrated last
year that was a great game I enjoyed
that game thoroughly some said Xbox and
SEO to uh we'll get to that because I do
have a theory on when it comes to some
of these things uh let
let's let's get
to 58 eight minutes let's talk about
good old
PlayStation and they had a huge
massive leak happened and I'm sure you
talked about this with with somniac it
was during our our time off so we didn't
really talk about it uh but I felt the
need to talk about it because apparently
I'm not allowed to talk about it uh so
yeah so I want to give like first off
give you over General sense of like what
you saw on on the the
leaks and I I don't know people okay
we'll get to that a second and then what
I want to talk about is do you think we
need to have a different approach when
we talk about
leaks do we need a different approach
um I wouldn't like me personally I
wouldn't be talking about a personal
information that leaked no but as far as
the game information we should talk
about it uh when Xbox information leak
we all talked about it Us Xbox channels
PlayStation channels media everybody
talked about it so this game information
that leaked with aiac yeah I I believe
we should talk about it when GTA 6
leaked everybody talked about it so yeah
man I
don't you know if you're if these people
decide not to talk about I think it's
pretty obvious why because they have
some personal relationships with the
somniac or or they're just
full of you know what see all right so
someone said um adct talk about the
human element first here's the thing I
don't think that's necessary because
unless I come out and say F the
developers we have sympathy for the
developers we hate that they're their
their their work got leaked but at the
same time protecting their work is not
my job reporting on their work is my job
so it's just like I could do both I
could easily multitask I can walk and
eat bubble gum okay and chew bubble gum
you know I hate that their stuff got
leaked but at the same time it is my
right to talk about it it is my right as
as an influencer to cover these stuff uh
you know we talk about the Wolverine
leaks if we want to now obviously when
it comes to certain stuff like that
there will be certain conditions I would
say stuff like spoiler alert if we go
over like specific details and that's
not for the industry that's just for my
audience I don't want to ruin anything
you guys don't want to see uh but at the
same time it's just like the reason I
didn't like what Greg did is because I
felt like he was trying to start a trend
that is a very deadly Trend because
these PR people these companies like
Microsoft uh play Sony and Playstation
they would love to be able to justify
blacklisting people for talking about
leaks
they would love it but the problem is
it's never okay in a lot of people's
minds to do stuff like
that a lot of people can't get away with
stuff like that and I think you know D
will agree if you came out there and
just started blacklisting people the
people you didn't Blacklist would speak
up but if you get people like like uh
Greg
big person in the industry to come out
there and say that and what's funny is
uh I I watch 3mgs uh not 3mg
um what's the dude
from okay you guys know him he's on
spawn ways
podcast what is his name oh uh rgt rgt
he said he said there's like a click
that goes to every event and every time
I saw someone speak out against this it
was them
it's like
look no one I didn't see one person on
and the crumbs side too I didn't see one
crumbside
person start saying yo we gonna leak all
these
people we gonna leak all the info I
didn't see none of that right because
you know why because in the general
sense of what's going on on the internet
no one cared about their information no
one went and looked for it we cared
about the information we
cover and it would be different if I saw
like big YouTubers or people that can
move the the needle covering and like yo
you know the that this person his stuff
got leak I didn't see one of those and
then it's like what dirt said the
inconsistency on reporting right where
was he when when the Xbox stuff got Le
because if you looked at his time stamps
he went over every individual Le and
then people say well it's because it was
it was a hostile thing you know they
hacked into it they invaded their
privacy
Capcom same thing got hacked ransomed
leaked what happened to
that and I and I and I saw people trying
to like reach and say that Greg's like
racist towards Asians and that's the
reason he didn't care about that that's
not right I don't think Greg is just
biased when it comes to miac games in a
lot of PlayStation stuff 100% so it's oh
and here's my thing maybe maybe I'm
wrong and dirt correct because you
always
do if Greg would have came out and said
we would love to cover these leaks but
we are too close to the situation we
were in Spider-Man 2 we don't want to we
want to stand with our friends so we're
going to step this one out guys do you
think they would have got any backlash I
would have respected that more they they
probably still would have got a little
backlash but I would have respected that
more CU they were being transparent just
the reason why the people that were
going to give them backlash for a
statement like that are probably the
same people that would have gave them
backlash for anything they said yeah any
reasonable person would have said I
respect you for coming out admitting
that you can't talk about this yeah y I
respect you for saying I got friends in
the building I I don't want personal
friends to upset anyone that I've been
around so I'm going step this one out I
would have respected that a lot more
brother but instead he went on his White
Horse and he tried to convince people
that we shouldn't be covering leaks in
general and that's where I have the
issue with because D you're you you're a
podcaster Conor how often do we speak
about rumors and leaks uh I would say
80% of the time eight a ridic ridiculous
amount Y and what's funny is he says
this now but then when something big
leaks he's going to put himself in a
shoe box I was I was just about to say
that when the next leak happened people
gonna go to to kind of funny games and
be looking at them like okay so um we're
waiting to hear what you're going to say
buddy go ahead because like you said
he's putting himself in the box right
now you the next leak come
out you you better be very careful how
you say what you say Greg Miller you got
to be very careful because people is
gonna they're going to have a a
magnifying glass on his channel kind of
funny games like yo
man and did you see did you see that
response to to the
backlash they say oh you know we think
it just made it worse it just okay let's
get the the Super Chat JD is going crazy
here $5 Super Chat from JD gamer
pathetic Port begging ponies got no
games # no PlayStation 6 ponies out here
Running Scared afraid of what Xbox will
do next Boo and got him jumping at
Shadows you know what's funny he's not
wrong I bet you PlayStation is literally
over there like every day they're like
we're going to wake up to them buying
another publisher like
tweet probably giving them like like um
what's that what's that word that you
have for post itic stress dendra pdsd or
whatever it's called yeah yeah I don't
want to butcher it but yeah it's they
probably given them that man five CH
from JD gamer Hypocrites are gonna do
what Hypocrites do hash no respect for
them or that BS say what you mean FAS
fella Greg was not right not on
mandatory Sunday you know what's funny
all this happened literally right after
IOP went on break yeah that was crazy
man you guys missed a whole lot of
juicy information but the whole thing
with kind of funny
games it's crazy but you think about
game gam spot they also said they're not
covering the leak like why are you guys
not covering the damn
leak why the Game Spot said we're not
covering the league it was so bad Tom
Warren was like yo man that's what I'm
worried about I'm worried that we're
we're doing this Grand standing stuff
yes and and because because we feel like
it's the positive way the industry is
going everyone decides to come together
and say we're not covering leaks and
then the pr people have what they feel
is justification I got enough of the
industry on my side I can start hitting
people for covering these
leaks it's crazy bro and that what's his
name tamore yeah he's a pony he's
another Pony bro like why do people
respect TMZ right I I mean some people
might not respect them but you better
believe if there's some some celebrity
news that came out and TMZ reported it
you better believe it's true you know
why because they do their homework they
don't care who feelings they hurt
they're there to do their job if they're
a papari their a gossip uh uh website
they are known to get 100% uh factual
information you know what it makes it
look bad it makes it look like they're
working for the companies you're not
supposed to work when they supposed to
cover them yeah right exactly bro that's
that that's why I use
TMZ as an
example with some news Dro you don't
hear them say well you know what Will
Smith is my friend we're not going to
talk about that no they if they don't
talk about it that's because they don't
know if it's 100% truth once they get
verification that a story is true TMZ
runs with it they don't give a damn who
they feelings they hurt they want to be
known as the the the the website with
the news yes people hate them they hate
them that their job is to just gossip
and be nosy and find out information
about people but guess what there's
millions of people that's just as nosy
as them and they care about it and they
go to TMZ for their celebrity news and
uh TMZ is good at what they do so it so
if you like them or not they're good at
what they do and and that's that that's
my thing is just like you know I just
don't want a scenario
where I I don't like the way PR's
handled these days and I don't blame PR
because I feel like PR is just doing
their job it's just I I feel like you
there's certain companies that will
Blacklist you for for your opinion it
doesn't matter if you're respectful now
most of them are pretty chill you know
when red fall happened you know we were
pretty hard on red fall but Bethesda
we're like look these people are being
genuine they're not attacking us they're
just giving us constructive criticism
and we're just going to have to take
that they still sent a Starfield they
still were respectful towards us I want
the majority of the industry to work on
that I want the majority of the industry
that if as long as you're respectful you
don't have to sit there and call they
game Trash you can easily convey your
message without talking [__] to their
game if you have an issue with the way a
game plays give examples of why you have
an issue of way their games played I
think there's way multiple ways of doing
respectful and then obviously a lot of
the bigger people make everyone bad they
go out there they say crazy ass stuff
and then before you know people getting
blacklisted for
nothing yep um hey chrisy Rambo yeah I
know TMZ pays money for the information
absolutely 100% but they want accurate
information they know they got to pay
for it that's what they do man so I was
just using that as a
example of a publication that's that's
not oh we don't want to cover that in
that or whatever man come on bro they
gonna talk about it you know so it's is
all Bs you ask me to be honest with
you H you think about like Addy brought
up red fall Phil Spencer was there at
that was that kind of funny games no uh
I forgot about what podcast that was but
he was
there when they was talking about damn
red fall he didn't run he was there to
talk about red far and you can tell on
on his face his body language he was
agitated he was pissed off but he didn't
run he was there to talk about rall
giant bomb thank you to talk about rare
fall
soever yeah it's just I just want a
better industry man you know and I I
might get upset of certain things
because you know we all just want we
want growth not only for the industry
but ourselves we want the industry to
work better I want better games I feel
like better criticism and a better path
to criticism leads to better games than
the overall you know there's no reason
why I feel like any Studio any publisher
I could I should be able to give my
opinion without having a backlash and I
do feel like there's certain people in
the industry if you're not big enough
they will put their foot on your neck
and say shut up and you have either two
choices at that point you shut up or you
no longer work with them and I feel like
certain people have shut up and then
they they won't even have a boot on
their neck they know the boot will come
to their neck so they don't even attempt
to go in that direction that's why
that's why I invented toxic positivity
you know people could say they invented
now I invented that sucker go look I've
been saying that for years I've been
that sucker sucker you gotta do the coat
man you gotta say sucker in the coat hey
sucker yeah to me I don't like when
people address a a negative with a
positive I don't like that I feel like
if you're going to address a
negative sometimes [__] smells like
[__] it doesn't need to be well you know
I like this but this is but at the end
of the day you know this might not be
your kind of game like you know I feel
them and I feel like that's
good that's good verbiage if that's what
you mean but sometimes when it comes to
the redfall thing there's not a lot of
positive to go in with the negative it's
just like look you guys got to do better
you got to do
better what's sometimes dirt smells like
dirt I don't know what that mean oh
neither do I we're gonna move on though
all right we're good last topic man last
topic let's get these super chats real
quick JD I appreciate all the support
you guys are giv today man $5 Super Chat
from JD
gamer here's the challenge for my
PlayStation brethen don't let Xbox fall
out of your mouth for the next year and
let's see how your channels do because
PS got nothing I like the the see I'm
I'm talking loud because that's how I'm
envisioning him saying this yeah JD is
hyped up bro we got a $5 sub from Jay
rambert I'm surprised other uh p uh
Playstation Fanboy uh Publications
didn't say what Greg and Gamespot said
to is uh uh toer tamr is definitely a PS
Fanboy um oh he's definitely a PS Fanboy
yeah I think the problem was is they
knew they couldn't get away with it yeah
when they saw now if if Greg Miller
wouldn't have got a lot of
backlash more people would have jumped
on that train but Greg Miller got hit
with a Spirit Bomb on top of a KEH May
wave and instant transported into the
damn
Sun so he knew okay let's just move on
because he didn't he didn't do a
follow-up followup he's I'm GNA take my
licks and walk away yeah but let's wait
to that next league and see what happens
$2 from JD gamer some sites should be
blacklisted they're bad actors I
completely agree $5 per trap from Simple
Jack yeah thought of pitching Philly p a
into the banjo verse for a while have
Spyro banjo crash as switchable
characters yeah that's what I'm saying
like imagine a Donkey Kong 64 modern
graphics with all of them characters and
you get to those characters by
individually making their individual
games and just throwing a banjo into a
crash game for a little bit they don't
even have to be there the whole time
just to show they're in the same
universe and then just put them all in
one
game i l my case we gotta find out super
from the angry therapist when he covered
other leaks he was laughing and clowning
these companies but they did not put him
in Spiderman that's true Hey listen when
the GTA um stuff leaked he was laughing
and having a good old time that's true
we got a $2 Super Chat from JD gamer
pathetic Port begging P's got no gam
hash no PlayStation 6 I like this JD guy
man we got a $5 check from beus barious
barious addict and wrecking ball head
how how you doing hope you have a great
year I'm ready for to Xbox bring uh the
the mo I assume that's the hammer from
uh god of war and Thor to these
PlayStation fans hey man don't call me
no damn wrecking ball
head imagine instead of like Miley Cyrus
like on a wrecking ball she's just on
like a big inflatable version of dirt
yeah exactly man come on bres don't you
start
oh all right let's get on to the last
one man PlayStation and Xbox road
map what do you expect this year what'll
start with
PlayStation I'm expecting third party
third party
exclusives I'm expecting what they have
announced I'm not expecting them to
announce something else that's dropping
later this year there could be obviously
but I'm expecting you know final fantasy
Riser Ronin Stellar yams um I'm
expecting them to have a better showcase
than they did last year I
mean everybody's expecting
that um but as far as games I think this
is going to be another light year for
PlayStation's first
party I'm not trying to be a fanboy here
even though I am a bot but I'm just
being honest I think there going to be
another light year with frost from their
first party but apparently first party
is not only about first party uh
addict yeah okay here's the
thing let's talk about that
PlayStation's gonna have a good year
because they're having other people do
this the work for them uh and it's not
nothing against that you know I've I
have been very vocal that a good timed
exclusive is just as effective as making
your own games yeah but how long could
that realistically hold on for them orx
has already really pretty much released
every game they have in the tuck rebirth
is the last one they won't have a final
fantasy in the to for a long
time because 16 just came out rebirth is
about to come out so what's after that
okay you you got like the little doublea
games and I think those are going to do
well and we're going to like
those but when people go into these
events they want PlayStation
games they want the games like Last of
Us they want the games like ghost of
Shima the PlayStation templates they
want those games and I don't for years I
remember doing the Xbox one generation I
don't know if you've been around since
the like the middle of the Xbox one
generation I've been around since
2014 okay I was around but just as a
person listening I I wasn't doing my own
content there's a lot of people back in
them days that are are are are are
lifting PlayStation from the ashes and
say we don't need those games we have
Final Fantasy 7 Reaper and holding him
up and they're the same people that said
yo we don't want Quantum break ain't
ain't yours we want first party
games don't get me started Edie you know
I got right son romate yours we W first
party games so guess what Xbox did from
that criticism they bought everything ad
don't get me started you know I got some
receipts don't you no no DT I'm okay
with them I love that they they tacked
Xbox from every angle because it's the
reason we got Bethesda is the reason we
got
ABK and what's funny is back then we
were even saying it they need a better
output that's why they bought those
first five Studios and then and then
they said they that ain't enough like
you guys are literally responsible for
your own downfall because you go out
there and you make podcasts every day
dedicated to place Xbox you talk about
Xbox every day in videos and then Xbox
okay we got you hold my beard they go
they they go to the Odin I need money
for what we shutting these these dudes
down we shutting them down we ain't
letting them back in the house he okay
how much you need everything so they
went to they went to Bethesda what do
you need I need everything what do you
mean everything I want my name on the
door so they did that and then you guys
said that wasn't enough then so then
then Phil went back to Odin I need
everything give but you already bought
everything I want more so then they
bought
ABK there you
go you can argue that if you guys were
spending more time talking about
PlayStation we wouldn't have
everything Call of Duty ain't Ys no more
he shared she dared she's everybody's
but she comes home to
us all right you go man hey um you know
I got so I actually had that receipt in
my last video bro of uh Jay duub saying
that look bro I had some
receipts I remember I hate how I didn't
clip these from podcast I us to listen
to back in the day there were
podcast that
said PlayStation no I'm sorry Xbox has
no games then XBox guys will say they do
have games what are you talking about
they say Xbox has no first party games
they said well they got some exclusives
they got you know certain games that was
that's not owned by them but no they
need first they have no first party
games except for Halo gears and
forer I remember this vividly it was so
bad kid mooth made a rap about it kid
moo made a rap about it you more because
that's what they were saying they have
no first party games besides Halo gears
and forer Halo gear no new
IPS I remember this stuff I have a few
not many but a few receips of people
saying Xbox has no games with it coming
out dirt pretty soon I'mma I'mma do my
oneman podcast tomorrow and talk about
some of that stuff but I'm seeing
PlayStation guys go out there pull up
PS2 charts say yo PlayStation always
been doing this talking about these
third party games I'm like that doesn't
matter because y'all said Xbox has no
games because they didn't have any first
party games besides Halo gears and forer
now since
2024 ex uh Playstation games are
only with the exception of a
remastered third party games maybe you
could say hell dyus is first party cuz
son's publishing
But now y'all are capping for these
third party exclusives when y'all made
fun of Xbox for years 2022 right they
destroyed Xbox did Xbox not have a
couple of thirdparty exclusive games in
2022 high on high on life I pretty I'm
pretty sure that was a exclusive for
like a year a third party exclusive they
didn't give us credit for that they
didn't give asbo credit for that but now
they want to say say oh game it's it's
great uh you know Final Fantasy and and
and rise and
Ronin and now they're pull out a tweet
that Phil Spencer said back in
2014 come on man come on BR I can't do
it no
more
yes
breathe breathe
D through the chest off the
mou look I I agree with you man uh
PlayStation I do feel is going to be
very lackluster in a lot of areas I do
think they're going to have really solid
experiences come out and you know maybe
we'll get like a ghost of shishima
announcement I
don't I don't think we're going to get
another year like this year where you
don't have a lot of games coming out in
general and not a lot of announcements I
do think they're going to to announce
stuff this year I do think we will see
announcements this year but as far as
like games coming out I don't think
we're going to see a lot of it I think
they're going to really go off as much
as they possibly can off what is
presented to them uh you know they they
might buy some time like smaller timed
exclusives they probably did that last
year or the beginning of last year so I
do think we're going to see some of
these I do but as far as like a go like
any of their first party like their
heavy hitter first
parties I don't I don't know that's I
don't know if that's gonna
happen adct I agree with you I believe
they will announce some of those games
at their showcase they they got no
choice at this point yeah yeah at this
point they have no choice we'll probably
see what Ben Studio was working on we'll
probably see what Sucker Punch is
working on um after that who knows but I
know the Naughty Dog wasted three years
on the damn game that that got cancelled
so it's like I don't know man um what
are they going to do but you know at
least they got counil sales right they
you know they got console sales so yeah
so we'll see I think it's it's good man
you know I think we're going to see more
aspects of PlayStation and and here's
the thing like for the most part and
obviously people joke people do people
clown but I don't really see too many
PlayStation people and uh Xbox people
just straight out deny PlayStation games
no for the most part Xbox people play
the PlayStation games and a lot of
ways I play more PlayStation games than
the PlayStation people you know I you
know besid how I I I I disagree how like
Jabari and them handle content sometimes
they're like one of the only people that
I know actually play
games there's been too many people been
exposed on the PlayStation Community for
not playing any of the PlayStation games
but they do nothing but ride and die for
them speaking of PlayStation I got that
this I got that one too is it red or
magenta that's that's the color of the
one I got but it's still in the box
though I haven't open it
bro what one of my friends owed me some
money I was like I take this
instead oh damn yeah he's like oh he was
all happy for it he's like yeah go for
it he he it's it's not it's it's magenta
I I think I think it's magenta uh it's
okay too like uh my my friend's
girlfriend says it's pink no it's not
this isn't I call it burgundy this is
like between pink and red like I I won't
say it's pink but I think it's more red
than pink oh 100% definitely burgundy
looking to
me so all right let's what's up Anthony
Smith let's move onth let's move on to
to Xbox how do you think Xbox is output
first party and third party and game p
this is that's the factor we could throw
in here is game pass because PlayStation
don't really contribute much to that
yeah I I feel Xbox is going to have
another solid year I thought 2023 was
solid I think 2024 is going to be solid
you know we mentioned some of the games
already like hell Blade 2 um Ty Bourn
hopefully goes of uh midnight I'm sorry
south of midnight drop this year um I'm
expecting them to have a pretty good
year stalker 2 now can we count that as
in damn exclusive since talking about
third party games count now yes totally
can no they no we see we taking that
[__] exactly that's another game um so
and I'm sure they're gonna have many
more games to announce we don't know if
a v is going to drop or it's going to be
delayed uh you know like the flight Sim
I didn't played the first one too long
but it was a very cool game though
driveing flying flying over my
neighborhood where I live was pretty
dope man um
but you know that's going to come out
this year so I'm expecting them to have
a pretty good year and moving forward
add Xbox is Never Gonna in my opinion
would never have another drought bro
unless something really bad happens I'll
never see them having another drought
like they did in 20122 ever again I
don't think they're gon have a drop but
I do think they're going to be lacking a
little bit like first party this year I
think you're gonna get hellblade you're
G to get um that one game what's that
game it looks really good too I just for
got the
name you said it when we were talking
towerb I think that game looks
phenomenal so I think you're going to
have that I think with with the vow if
it does get pushed back to 2025 it's
going to leave them a little bit of a
lighter year than they would have
originally had but I think they're gonna
have phenomenal I think we we're going
to see a gears collection most likely
this year so I I think they're going to
be there but the games that we see now I
think it's going to be curious on
whether or not it actually like delivers
or not uh so but but I do think they're
gonna have a good year yeah it's just I
don't stalker 2 I can see that I I I
here's my thing I don't think I do think
they have a good look I I'm not saying
Xbox is gonna have a bad year Game Pass
thirdparty titles that they've secured
and hellblade along with most likely uh
you know the coalition's game whatever
they're doing I think you'll get an
announcement I think they're going to
have phenomenal year but me personally I
want a vow I don't care about hellblade
so people that don't really are excited
about hellblade I think we're going to
be more disappointed going in to
2024 yeah um yeah I think esp's gonna
have a great year man
um I don't
know like them dropping four to five
first party games a couple Triple A's a
couple Double A's I think it's pretty
dope I think that's a pretty good year
so yeah yeah so but see that and I think
I'm going from like the standpoint I
felt like this year was a last year was
a phenomenal year like I feel like last
year besides redf fall you know even
even if you didn't like Forza
Motorsports to degree it was still a
solid experience Starfield solid
experience high-fi Rush solid experience
uh you know Minecraft Legends I I know a
lot of people were like up and down with
that solid experience
uh I felt like last year is going to be
a better year than this
year yeah I mean Starfield is pry big
but I I don't
know I mean like we'll see I think both
years are going to be solid um no I
think they're both going to be good I'm
just talking about from what the year we
left and that might just be off of Total
2023 oh hey star star traffic thank you
adct we gotta put Call of Duty in our
first party list
now I feel you and I that's fair I thank
you star traffic you're right we got to
start putting Call of Duties in our
first party list bro technically they
our first party okay Call of Duty once
again I don't care about Call of Duty so
can we move
on that you gotta put that in the list
now man all right let me get first list
let me get these super chats so we can
uh get out of here five $2 Super Chat
for the angry therapist they're going to
announce Spider-Man 2
remaster $5 Super Chat from JD gamer did
y'all see the ponies went and looked up
a 2014 quote from Phil to change their
own narrative yet again Xbox has a
problem of having too many games JD I
sure did see it bro I was like wow it's
unbelievable dirt TTS let me see those
receipts please I got a couple of them
bro $2 shot from dirt I need that video
dirt another narrative CH yeah I'll
probably do it probably tomorrow yeah
fight from JD gamer Naughty Dog wasted
nine years on Faction five years while
doing the main the mainline The Last of
Us then four since the Last of Us Part
Two 2019 releas what a waste what's the
PlayStation method oh I feel you Donna
talku did I miss the Nintendo discussion
no you didn't I'll give my overall
opinion real quick maybe you could jump
in if you want I think Nintendo was a
very mystery year because I think this
is the year they launched the switch to
and I don't want to like give a whole
lot of cuz here's the thing Nintendo you
might come out here you might talk all
that spicy nonsense but I play a lot of
Nintendo games yeah I I I played the the
Mario RPG I played Zelda I played
wonders I played uh Advanced Wars one
and
two you can argue that maybe I play more
Nintendo games than you
D I don't know is that a CH maybe I do I
don't
know JD gamer pick between these three
games that you could have Xbox make one
rise two coner or scalebound rise too F
yeah F conquer and f scale bound I don't
even want conquer to be around I don't
even want conquer to be around I'm gonna
be right with you I would take rise two
over scalebound on conquer any day of
the week and and that's not even say
nothing about scalebound I think
scalebound would be a like a drop mic
moment if they imagine if they announce
a scalebound at the end of an E3 or
whatever they want to call that show and
it's a good
game yeah that'd be imagine if they
announced scalebound and it dropped day
and date with the announcement and it
was a good game like a 90 Plus game hey
even though I just said f scale bound if
that happened I be like yeah let's go
baby oh my God all right come on Bon say
you don't my C on damn tur
Rock appreciate for coming through we
had uh 400 like three people bought the
the highest in here you guys you guys
showed up first episode back I think I
think uh you know we we we definitely
delivered for you guys I'm GNA put it in
the the chat again you know that is the
chat for the atct show and for some
reason uh not the addict show it's the
chat for the addict Arena adct Arena the
addict arena is my live show uh my live
my streaming channel so definitely go to
that sub if you guys want that kind of
information uh you know I want to thank
everyone for coming on it was a uh I
thank Dart again you know it's been a
been a very eventful holiday I can
actually say I you know I op's back
Sunday so I I think uh you know we're
gonna have a good little time Sunday U
we are going to be covering some of the
stuff that happened outside of the uh
our break and obviously Insomniac leag
is one of those so it's going to be
interesting man it's going to be
interesting I think his only fans
Channel no I do not have an only fans
Channel I really feel truly feel like
these people want me to have only fans
like I truly believe that at this point
so I appreciate every you know where
we're gonna send
everyone and definitely dirt right there
uh check out my channel guys yeah D what
what what what do you got going on are
you gonna you gonna do that video soon
yeah I'll probably do it um probably
tomorrow afternoon because um I have my
woman podcast tomorrow but I I'll do it
in so you know it'll probably be ready
Friday or something like that yeah yeah
the Lions did get cheated JD gamer he
said DT did you see the Lions get
cheated yes I saw it clear as day with
all four of my eyes I saw
it yeah appreciate that so all right all
right all right who we sending to we
uh no one's you know what we were
talking about him guys look I'm G to
send you the Jack Mo Johnny he's he's
live streaming Allen wake 2 right now I
know some of you probably feel away
about Jack move uh go over there get
show him some love man he he he he's on
this grind all the time go over there
and show him some love tell him adct
adct you came from the atct world go
there drop a like man just show them
some Love sometimes just having an
influence of people show up and some new
people you ain't never seen like will
really brighten up people's day this
this this streaming in this podcast
stuff is very mentally draining and I'm
sure dirt can attend to that uh so go
over there and show them some love guys
and uh anything else you want to say dir
fry take him over there that's it man
holl at you guys see you guys next
time